Hallo, guten Tag.
Bitte schön.
Hallo.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich bin ein Erstens auf dieser Station tätig.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Ja, sehr gut.
So, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Verena Hofer.
Verena Hofer, Frau Hofer.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Namen und Nachnamen bestebieren?
Ja, mein Vorname ist Frau I-R-I-N-A, Verena.
Okay.
Und der Nachname ist Hofer-H-O-F-I-R.
Ja, sehr gut.
Frau Hofer, wie heißen Sie?
38 Jahre.
38.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren, Frau Hofer?
Am 4. März 1985.
Okay, sehr gut.
Wie viel wiegen Sie, Frau Hofer?
29.
Wiegen 59 Kilo?
59, okay, sehr gut.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Hofer?
1,72 m.
1,72 m, okay.
So, Frau Hofer, was kann ich mir tun?
Was für Sie zu uns?
Ja, vor ungefähr 2 Stunden habe ich ganz plötzlich Luftnot bekommen.
Und mein Puls war ganz schnell.
Und ich habe auch Schmerzen.
Ja, ich habe auch Schmerzen im linken Brustkorb.
So auf der ganzen Seite.
Ja, ich bin sehr unruhig, weil ich so schlecht Luft kriege.
Und die Atmung ist auch schneller.
Schmerz auf der linken Brustseite.
Okay, so, Strahlen auch vielleicht rücken?
Schmerzen aus?
Nein, nicht so richtig.
Also Sie sind so auf der ganzen Seite.
Ja, direkt tun Sie nicht.
Okay, so, 2 Stunden.
Wie stark ist diese Schmerz, Frau Hofer?
In einer Schmerzskala 0 bis 10, wobei 0 ist keine Schmerzen.
Und 10 ist sehr starkes Schmerzen entspricht.
Ja, ich würde sagen 7.
7, okay, so, okay.
Ist Schmerzen sich im Verlauf der Seite verschlechtert?
Nein, also die gingen ganz schnell los.
Das ging so ganz plötzlich.
Und jetzt sind sie vielleicht etwas weniger geworden, aber sie sind immer noch sehr stark.
Okay, ich will ein bisschen beschreiben,
welche Charakter haben die Schmerzen?
Ja, sie sind mehr so dumpf.
Ja, dumpf würde ich sagen.
Und wenn ich tiefer atmen will, verstärkt sich der Schmerz.
Okay, ich war dann etwas schlecht.
Ja, okay, so, ist diese Schmerzenlage abhängig, Frau Hofer?
Nein, ich kann mich nicht hinlegen,
aber ich komme noch schlechter, dann Luft.
Ich muss mich eigentlich immer hinsetzen.
Okay, sie müssen immer hinsetzen.
Sie haben diese Schmerzen gehabt, Frau Hofer, oder haben sie schon mal?
Sowas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Erst einmal, okay.
Okay, so, haben sie auch noch ein bisschen werden.
Sie haben gesagt, sie haben Altennot
und haben sie andere Beschwader.
Zur Zeit noch andere Beschwerden?
Ja, genau.
Ja, ich kann seit einer Woche keinen Sport mehr machen,
weil ich bin vor einer Woche,
seit einer Woche bin ich umgeknickt mit dem linken Sprung,
Fuß, ein Knöchel.
Und da ist der Knöchel ziemlich dick geworden.
Ich habe das bandagiert und habe seitdem keinen Sport gemacht.
Ich mache sonst sehr viel Sport.
Okay, okay.
Gerade ich meine, haben sie,
ihr seid schwindelig oder haben sie,
haben sie,
Entschuldigung, zum Beispiel haben sie...
Nach Schweiß.
Ja, nach Schweiß, oder kalt Schweiß.
Als das eben so losging, da habe ich auch ein Schweißausbruch bekommen.
Aber nach Schweiß habe ich sonst nicht.
Nein, das habe ich.
Ich weiß.
Okay, haben sie Schüttelfroß?
Nein.
Kein Schüttelfroß.
Okay, gut.
Vielleicht haben sie,
haben sie Schrauchhofer,
andere Beschwerden, Fieber zum Beispiel.
Nein, Fieber habe ich auch nicht.
Keine Fieber, sehr gut.
Kopfschmerzen?
Nein.
Diarröhe oder?
Was ist Diarröhe?
Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung,
haben sie Verstoffung oder Durchfall?
Ja, ich hatte früher Durchfall häufiger
und dann hat man festgestellt,
dass ich eine Lutenunverträglichkeit habe.
Ach, okay.
Bei dem war dort eine Diät-Einhalte,
da habe ich keine Durchfälle mehr
und auch keine Bauchschmerzen mehr.
Ich habe gerade keine Beschwerden.
Okay, so als Vorerkrankungen
von Schrauchhofer haben sie irgendwelche Erkrankungen.
Einmal seit vor fünf Jahren
wurde diese Glutenunverträglichkeit festgestellt
und dann habe ich im Frühjahr immer starken Heuschnupfen
und dann habe ich auch teilweise Asthma
während dieser Heuschnupfenzeit.
Okay, seit wann?
Ja, seit 20 Jahren.
Und da muss ich auch Tabletten nehmen,
Anti-Allergie-Tabletten
und auch manchmal Asthma-Sprei,
sonst kann ich keinen Sport machen.
Okay, wissen Sie, wie heißt diese Medikamentin?
Schrauchhofer, das Anteil allergiekt.
Also das Asthma-Sprei heißt Salutamol.
Und im Moment dieses Jahr war ein neues,
das kann ich mich nicht mehr erinnern.
Ich kann mich jetzt auch nicht mehr nehmen.
Das geht meist bis Ende Mai und dann hört das auf.
Oh, welche Medikamentin?
Entschuldigung, Asthma-Sprei oder Anti-Allergie-Tabletten?
Diese Anti-Allergie-Tabletten,
die kann ich im Augenblick nicht erinnern.
Den Zettel habe ich zu Hause.
Okay, bis am Ende Mai, Sie haben gesagt?
Meistens geht das so von April bis Mai
mit dieser Symptom, mit diesem Zettel.
Okay, okay, okay, nicht immer.
Wie viel Mal pro Tag benutzen Sie, Schrauchhofer?
Ja, wenn es je nachdem, wie stark das ist.
Manchmal muss ich dreimal sprühen, viermal.
Und mich von den Tabletten habe ich jetzt immer zwei genommen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich weiß den Namen jetzt gerade nicht.
Okay, so kam letztes Mal einmal pro Tag.
Und Spree manchmal, dreimal manchmal viermal.
Ja, ja.
Ich verstehe, okay.
So haben Sie andere Korrektankungen,
vielleicht Blutfurchtdruck, die sind sehr jung, aber...
Blutfurcht habe ich nicht.
Oder Blutfurcht-Zukau?
Nein.
Ja, okay, sehr gut.
Blutfurcht, ja, ich verstehe, sehr gut.
Frau Hofer, nehmen Sie, Sie haben gesagt,
Anti-Allergie und Asthma-Sprei
benutzen Sie vielleicht andere Medikamente ein.
Ich bin gerne mit Sie gut ab und zu.
Sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Keine Medikamente, sehr gut.
Wurden Sie schon operiert, Frau Hofer?
Ja, als Kind wurde ich Blindheim operiert, da war ich, glaube ich, 10 Jahre alt.
Ich war auch schon 10 Jahre alt.
Ja, Blindheim.
Und dann hatte ich einen Bruch im Außenknöchel rechts.
Außenknöchel, da war ich 21, da bin ich beim Joggen auch umgeknickt
und da war der Knöchel gebrochen, das wurde operiert.
Okay, wo diese Knöchel genau?
Ja, rechtes, wie heißt das?
Rechtes Sprunggelenk.
Rechtes Sprunggelenk, okay.
So, diese Operationen waren Konstruktionen oder...?
Wir sind gut vorlaufen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Sie haben eine gute Lüstung mit Unverträglichkeiten.
Und haben Sie andere Allergen, oder?
Ist auch Glutenen, Unverträglichkeit habe ich keine Unverträglichkeiten.
Geht es sonst?
Okay, sehr gut.
Frau Hofer, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Sehr gut.
So, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber ganz unregelmäßig, vielleicht mal auf einer Feier,
oder einem Feiertag, aber das ist ganz selten.
Vielleicht einmal im Monat trinke ich vielleicht mal ein Glas Wein,
aber das ist wirklich selten.
Ah, okay, sehr gut.
So, bitte nehmen Sie Personie, Frau Hofer,
oder ist ein Steinberg mit den Fragen?
Ich nehme noch ein Medikament, ich nehme die Pille.
Aha, okay, Pille, okay.
Einmal Crotac, oder?
Ja.
Okay, sehr gut.
Wie sind Sie?
Wie heißt diese Medikament, diese Pille?
Ich bin gerade so aufgeregt, zurzeit muss ich Ihnen nachher sagen.
Ich muss das noch mal aussuchen.
Ja, alles klar.
Okay, so, Frau Hofer, bitte nehmen Sie persönlich
die seinstandardmäßige Frage,
nehmen Sie sonst gedrohnen.
Nein.
Okay, kein Problem, sehr gut.
Okay, so, Sie haben gesagt, Sie nehmen Pille.
Wann war Ihre letzte Periode?
Haben Sie Probleme?
Nein, normalerweise nicht.
Ja, auch regelmäßig, auch regelmäßig.
Ich bin begegnet.
Ich bin eine Gynäkologin.
Sehr gut, wann war Ihre letzte Periode?
Na vor 14 Tagen.
Vor 14 Tagen. Wie alt waren Sie, wenn Sie haben, erst die Periode bekommen?
12.
12 Jahre. Okay, sehr gut.
So, Krauch Rofa, die Sie beheiratet?
Nein.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Haben Sie im Lebensleben gefällt oder Freund?
Ich habe einen Partner.
Sie haben einen Partner.
Okay, sehr gut, Sie haben keine Kinder.
Was machen Sie da wirklich?
Ich bin Programmiererin in einem IT-Unternehmen.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme mit Ihrem Job?
Nein, es ist ein anstrengender Job, aber ich mache ihn gerne.
Sehr gut.
Okay, so sind Ihre Eltern gesund, Frau Rofa?
Mein Vater ist 66 Jahre alt, der hat eine Herzkranzgefäßerkrankung.
Bei Jahren bekam er drei Stens.
Oh, okay.
Es geht ihm soweit jetzt aber ganz gut.
Also hat er andere Erkrankungen auch oder nur das?
Nein, nein.
Sonst hat er ein bisschen Arthrose in den Fingern,
aber die Ärzte sagen, es ist kein entzündliches Rheume, es ist Arthrose.
Okay, sehr gut.
Frau Rofa, ist Ihre Mutter auch gesund oder hat sie?
Meine Mutter ist 65 Jahre alt.
65?
65, die hatte schon in den letzten Jahren eigentlich schon mehrfach
Venentrombosen in den Beinen.
Oh, okay, Beine, beide Beine?
Ja, ich glaube, es waren beide Beine.
Ja, okay.
So haben Sie Geschwister, Frau Rofa?
Ja, eine Schwester, die ist zwei Jahre älter.
Die hatte eine Beinvenentrombose nach Kaiserschnitt,
nach der Geburt, also Ihres Kindes.
Das war vor fünf Jahren.
Vor fünf Jahren.
Ja, okay, so ist es mir so vielleicht.
Frau Rofa, ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas mir sagen, etwas besonders,
von denen ich mussten sollen?
Ja, also ich frage mich, was kann das sein?
Das war so plötzlich gekommen jetzt gerade.
Das war auch sehr bedrohlich, es ist immer noch sehr bedrohlich,
aber ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Ja, ich möchte ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Frau Rofa, leider ich kann jetzt sehr wenig ihr sagen.
Deswegen, so als ich möchte, Sie gehört perlig unterzuchen
und ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ja, aber mein Verlachdiagnose ist, es kann ja etwas mit Herz,
vielleicht haben Probleme mit Herz.
Okay.
Deswegen, so als ich möchte, sofort meine EKG durchführen
und Laboacemi, ja, danach nicht können, ich glaube mehr sagen.
Okay, gut.
Mehr Informationen in den Geruch.
Okay, können andere Kollegen, haben andere Kollegen noch Fragen?
Hören Sie mich?
Ja, unten gibt es eine Frage, geschwollene Beine habe ich gelesen,
aber ich kann es nicht alles lesen.
Haben wir etwas fragen?
Ja, bitte.
Haben Sie esagten Luftnot?
In Gleise seid, haben Sie verlohlen Bewusstsein?
Können Sie das noch einmal wiederholen?
Haben Sie Ihre Bewusstsein verlohlen?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie eine Wusten?
Wusten?
Nein, Wusten muss ich jetzt auch nicht, sonst habe ich eigentlich
ganz selten Wusten, aber jetzt muss ich jetzt auch nicht mehr Wusten.
Könnten Sie vor einer Woche einen Unfall genau beschreiben?
Ja, da bin ich beim Joggen mit dem Fuß umgeknickt.
Welche Fuß, rechte oder?
Im linken Fuß, der rechte Fuß wurde schon mal operiert vor.
Aber ich bin jetzt mit dem linken Fuß umgeknickt und dann wurde das auch ziemlich dick.
Und dann habe ich gekühlt und bandagiert und hochgelegt.
Und in den letzten Tagen ist das Bein auch ein bisschen geschwollt,
der Unterschenkel am Knöchel auch.
Und ich habe dann eben mich geschont.
Ich konnte gar nicht mehr joggen, sonst jogge ich ja sehr viel.
Deswegen sind Sie eine Arsbesuchung, diese Unfall?
Nein, ich war nicht beim Arsbesuch.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt.
Wir haben eine Diagnose benken.
Können wir als Ersatzgeschichte anfangen oder?
Ja, natürlich.
Hallo, guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe gerade eine Aufnahme.
Bitte schön.
Ja, ich kann nicht mit meinen Patienten das ernst sehen.
Ja, bitte schön.
Hallo, Herr Oberarzt, ich habe gerade ein Patient aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen, wenn Sie gesagt haben.
Ja, okay, danke schön.
Frau Werner Hofer, 38 Jahre alt, 14 März 1985,
59 Kilogramm und 1,72 Meter groß.
Und hat sich bei uns wegen seit zwei Stunden
plöster aufgetretener Torachsschmerzen links vorgestellt.
Die Schmerzen hätten plötzlich angefangen.
Sie sind dumpf und in einer unschmerzenden State
ist sieben und zehn Patienten.
Die Patienten haben Probleme beim Atmen.
Die Patienten haben Luftnoten.
Die Schmerzen haben sich nicht verschwärzt.
Schmerzen haben sich ein bisschen vermindert.
Patienten haben gesagt, er kann nichts hinlegen,
sondern es muss immer hinsetzen.
Diese Schmerzen hätten zum ersten Mal passiert.
Und auch der Patient hat ihre Knochen,
Linken, Knochen, Pulsknochen schädigt.
Vor einer Woche berichtet die Patientin,
habe sie eine Distortion im linken Sprunggelenk erlitten.
Ja, linken Sprunggelenk erlitten.
Die anderen Fragen, wie Fieber, Schmerzen, Stilfrost,
Schweigbruch, Verstoffung, wurden verleinzt.
Die Patientin habe Durchfall.
Aber sie berichtet es wegen Gulitäranlage.
Besteht bei der Patientin eine seit fünf Jahren bekannte Proteinunverträglichkeit?
Ja, genau.
Seinerzeit hatte sie Symptome wie bei einer Zeliaki mit Durchfällen, Bauchschmerzen?
Und als Vorerkrankungen, sie hat seit fünf Jahren bekannte Asthma.
Seit 20 Jahren, ich schulde.
Nein, seit 20 Jahren eine saisonale Polynosis mit Asthma-Symptomatik.
Patientin nehme Medikamente gegen diese Asthma-Polynosis.
Polynosis, Antialergie, Antialergie, Tablets.
Tablets nimmt ein Antialergikum, so wie Salbutamolspray.
Das Antialergikum kann die Patientin zurzeit nicht benennen.
Nichts.
Im Namen des Antialergikums kann die Patientin nicht benennen.
Ja, genau.
Gibt es sonst Risikokonstellationen bei der Patientin?
Diese Risiko, wegen dieser Schmerzen, meinen Sie?
Wegen der Symptome, die die Patientin bietet.
Die Patientin bietet?
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, eigentlich wegen dieser.
Raucht die Patientin?
Ist die Patientin übergewichtig?
Nein.
Raucht nicht?
Raucht nicht. Alkohol ist sehr wenig Alkohol.
Patientin konsumiert sehr wenig Alkohol.
Patientin ist sehr sportlich, treibt regelmäßig Ausdauersport?
Ja, aber seit ein Wochen wegen dieser Fußluxation,
meine ich, wegen dieser.
Distortion, Distortion.
Distortion ist eine Bänderzerrung.
Eine Bänder, keine Luxation.
Luxation wäre ja noch dramatischer.
Aha, okay.
Es besteht, die Patientin hat eine Sportpause seit einer Woche.
Ja, genau.
Bezüglich dieser Beschwerden bisher keinen Arzt aufgesucht.
Ja?
Ja.
Gibt es Risikokonstellationen in der Familie?
Ja, genau.
Der Vater hat drei Herzständen.
Der Vater hat 36 Jahre alt, hat eine kannte coronare Herzerkrankung
und Zustand nach Dreifachständung vor drei Jahren.
Ja.
Und Arturo, die Patientin hat eine ganze Herzerkrankung.
Und Arturo, die andere, der Vater ist Arthrose im Finger.
Ja, okay.
Besonders unabhängig.
Mutter ist 65-jährige Mutter, hatte wenig Thrombose.
Letzte Jahr.
Auffällig bei der fünf Wochen.
Ja, die drei Jahre.
Okay.
Letzte Jahr.
Auffällig bei der 65-jährigen Mutter.
Sind mehrere Beinwähnen Thrombosen innerhalb der letzten Jahre.
Mehrere.
Beinwähnen Thrombosen innerhalb der letzten Jahre.
Und gibt es Geschwister?
Ja, sie hat eine zwei Jahre älter Schwester.
Sie liegt an Wenen Thrombose nach Cessarion Sexio vor fünf Jahren.
Ja, okay.
Gut, also, woran denken Sie jetzt bei dieser Konstellation?
Sie berichten, wenn ich das wiederholen darf, über eine Patientin,
die vor zwei Stunden eine akute Dispnel.
Ja, genau.
Zuerst war die Dispel begleitet von einem starken Schmerz.
Links.
Woran denken Sie bei dieser Symptomatik und bei der Vorgeschichte?
Ja, ich denke, ich möchte mein Vater Diagnose Lungenembole.
Aber so nach ich möchte Miokartinfarkt einschließen.
Ja, gut.
Und weshalb denken Sie an eine Lungenembole?
Ja.
Warum?
Weil es ist diese Distortion.
Ja.
Vielleicht, ich glaube es.
Ja, in der Vorgeschichte ein Bagatell-Trauma am linken Sprungling
mit Schwellung des Unterschenkels.
Ja, genau.
Und das ist ein Stück Lücke, das ist auch Beinens-Gycows.
Gibt es eventuell doch eine Auffälligkeit in der Familienvorgeschichte?
Die Mutter hat mehrere Beinwählentrum-Bosen.
Ja, genau.
Die Patientin nimmt die Pille.
Eventuell auch daran denken, dass eine Grinnungsstörung in der Familie vorliegt,
die bisher noch nicht entdeckt worden ist.
Ja.
Und muss man sicherlich neben der Akutdiagnostik, die jetzt laufen,
muss dran denken, weil das ist ja schon auffällig,
dass die Mutter mehrere Beinwählentrum-Bosen hatte.
Die Schwester hat eine nach Sektio und jetzt die Patientin nach
diesem Bagatell-Trauma.
Das muss keine Grinnungsstörung sein,
aber es sollte man auf alle Fälle ausschließen, daran denken.
Gut.
Was steht?
Ich bin mit Ihrer Verdachtdiagnose einverstanden.
Was gelbe differenzial diagnostisch noch in Frage?
Sie sparen von Myokatinfargt.
Mein Vater hat nicht auch eine Erkrankung.
Ja.
Und diese Symptome ist linke Brustschmerzen.
Man hat links Torkschmerzen,
plötlich sehr starkes Schmerzen.
Schmerzen kann.
Gut.
Myokatinfargt ist passieren oder Corona-Schmerzen.
Okay.
Bei Ihrer Bildung, bei der Vorstellung, ist mir aufgefallen,
dass Sie relativ wenig medizinische Fachausdrücke benutzt haben.
Sie sprachen von Durchfall.
Sie sprachen von einer Verstopfung.
Sie sprachen von Durchfall Diarrhöl.
Das versuchen Sie, Sie zu beben sich,
dass Sie das lithium-Penso suspectieren.
Sie sprachen von Durchfall Diarrhöl.
Die Zeit haben Vorbereitung, dass Sie hinschreiben.
Durchfall gleich Diarrhöl.
Und die Patientin stellte sich eben vor, dass war das erste vor zwei Stunden akute Luftnot.
Dann heißt das wegen einer, richtet über eine akute Disple mit links-torakalen Schmerzsymptomatik
oder mit einer links-torakalen Schmerzsymptomatik.
Dazu kommt, dass in der Anamnese Vorgeschichte vor acht Tagen oder vor einer Woche
Bakatelltrauma, wohl in Form einer OSG, Distortion, linkes Sprunggelenk,
ist ja meistens ein sogenanntes Subminationstrauma, was da passiert beim joggen,
die Leute also subinieren und dann umknicken und das führt dann oft zu den entsprechenden
entweder Wand-Läsionen oder auch zu Hematomen, die eben dann zu dieser Schwellung
im Unterschäkel geführt haben und dann wahrscheinlich zu einer Thrombose und dann zu dem Embulus.
Wichtig wäre vielleicht bei dieser Akutsymptomatik gewesen,
das haben sie dann später gemacht, ich mache noch eine EKG,
dass sie ruhig sagen bei der Erstschilderung dieser Beschwerden, dass sie sagen,
Frau Hofer, ich mache jetzt gerade mit ihnen eine EKG und messe ihren Sauerstoffgehalt im Blut,
messe ihren Blutdruck.
Das wäre so eine Erstversorgung, die vielleicht für die Patientin beruhigend wirkt
und wo sie sich schon mal ein Bild verschaffen können und wo sie dann auch sagen können,
wenn der Oberarzt fragt, wie ist der Blutdruck oder wie ist das EKG, dann können sie schon sagen,
ich habe das hier gemacht, das EKG und das ist der Aufnahmebefund oder ich hänge die Patientin
an einem Monitor um zu sehen, hat die Patientin vielleicht Rhythmusstörungen
bei diesem Beschwerdebild.
Das wäre hilfreich, glaube ich.
Hauptsächlich daran denken die Schilderung, die Worte der Patientin,
umsetzen in medizinische Begriffe, weil das möchte ja der Oberarzt hören
oder soll ja bei der Prüfung auch möglichst, wird ja abgefragt oder auch gewünscht
und gefordert und dass sie das vielleicht nochmal in ihrem eigenen Training nochmal
in den Bordern stellen.
Ja, meine Kollegin hat heute...
Wann haben Sie Prüfung?
Mit August.
Mit August, okay.
Gut, ich habe jetzt...